advice here with another new rock stars
hot day Christopher Nolan's Oppenheimer
is going to tell us the real world
history of J Robert Oppenheimer and his
work with the Manhattan Project to
develop the atomic bomb during World War
II Nolan actually referenced Oppenheimer
in the movie tenant you're familiar with
the Manhattan Project as they approach
the first atomic test open Hammer became
concerned that the detonation might
produce a chain reaction and cutting the
world obviously tenet is sci-fi
Oppenheimer is real history but in
Nolan's mind Oppenheimer was a futurist
haunted by horrific features that were
brought about by nuclear technology and
tenet a world where future time
inversion technology is hidden in
radioactive nuclear test sites is one of
those hypothetical Horrors so kind of
like that theory where Quentin
Tarantino's movie reality exists in a
world where World War II ended in a
cinema fire and in glorious bastards and
then that led to his Society of uber
violent cinephiles I think Christopher
Nolan could also be inventing a new way
for films to be meta textually connected
let me know what you think And subscribe
to new rockstars